selon vous qui a dit je suis noir même
si ça ne se voit pas à l'oeil nu j'ai
pas encore Donald Trump Clémentine
Célarié Laurent Blanc
[Applaudissements]
et Florian absolument absolument
Clémentine Célarié regardez ce qu'elle a
dit c'était sur France 2
j'ai un côté très con c'est que moi je
suis noir ah oui c'est ça parce que j'ai
lu ça je suis attiré
noir c'est comme ça je ne sais que vous
êtes noir comment vous pensez que vous
êtes noir je ne pense pas je suis c'est
à dire que je suis né en Afrique je suis
africaine ça ne se voit pas donc
forcément c'est embêtant mais si vous
voulez il y a plein de choses qui ne se
voient pas à lui du
[Applaudissements]
elle a dit ça parce qu'en fait
effectivement elle est née en Afrique
elle a toujours eu des liens avec le
continent africain très fort et elle se
sent très proche des gens qui qui sont
nés et qu'on grandit là-bas donc c'est
pour ça qu'elle l'a dit sauf que ça a
été relativement mal pris par beaucoup
de gens
aussi et voilà donc elle a été
extrêmement critiquée elle est obligé de
se reprendre de refaire une déclaration
d'expliquer d'aller dans le détail de
pourquoi
elle aime tellement l'Afrique noir et
l'Afrique et la culture qu'elle a
l'impression que c'est le sang coule en
elle je me sens
africaine
donc c'est peut-être mais bien sûr
non elle a pas épousé elle a eu des amis
avec qui voilà non elle a eu des enfants
métisses
sur Twitter quand même et oui c'est le
souci de mes lunettes perdues être né en
Afrique ne fait pas des lunes noires je
suis né en France ça ne fait pas de moi
une blanche et clairement la société
aime le rappeler c'est super on pourra
l'embaucher tout en validant les quotas
diversité
tout est là cette logorrhée de conneries
bourgeoise ce qu'il faut pas entendre
comme connerie elle peut se sentir
africaine si elle est née en Afrique
mais pas dire qu'elle se sent noire
ça part d'un bon sentiment parce que
j'en pense après je pense ça part d'un
bon sentiment elle c'était elle voulait
dire quelque chose qui était empathique
qui était sympa et puis en fait ça c'est
quelque chose qui est un peu maladroit
qui peut être mal perçu etc voilà qu'on
sait pas clair forcément ça c'est aussi
la contamination de la culture
américaine qui maintenant vraiment nous
envahit à ce niveau là c'est le problème
d'appropriation que culturel qui est qui
maintenant devient c'est le
politiquement incorrect voilà
on va chercher si loin elle a juste le
sens de la formule elle aime bien en
faire donc elle en a dit une maintenant
par rapport à toi globalement maintenant
elle a toujours un petit côté bobo
gaucho décalé
elle avait fait BFM elle est arrivée un
matin sur BFM le cheveu comme ça et tout
ça sur la matinale et la vidéo là là le
covid aussi une maladie mais oh c'est
l'amour faites-vous des bisous
faites-vous des bisous faites-vous des
bisous c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
elle est folle par exemple je me sens en
femme et je suis pas une femme vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est vrai je sens que j'ai une très
grosse part de féminité en moi plus de
50% et pourtant plus de 50 % ah ouais je
pense que je me sens plus fort que femme
à part mon sexe je pense que tout le
reste c'est une femme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
documentaire sur TF1 pour TF1 sur Benoît
et on va interviewer sa maman à
Villeneuve-sur-Yonne pas pardon dans une
ville sa maman et on interview et je dis
à sa maman à quel moment vous vous avez
senti que votre fils était comme on dit
différent
qui met ça du tout oh on est 17 et très
simple à 4 ans il avait une collection
de talons de talons hauts
c'est vrai tout petit je m'habille en
femme j'ai toujours aimé le côté féminin
le cultiver
dans mon corps d'homme j'aime j'aime mon
corps d'homme je cultive le travail je
fais du sport mais par contre
intérieurement psychologiquement je
pense que je réfléchis comme une femme
une vieille femme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui commentent tout ça et que et tous
les quatre matins la guerre en Ukraine
ils connaissent pas les 5 et 50000 morts
en Syrie ils connaissent pas ils vont
ils vont noter la phrase à côté de
Clémentine Célarié
on s'en fout c'est vrai qu'elle a le
sens de la formule mais elle a aussi le
sens de la démonstration souvenez-vous
il y a plein
absolument
je vais vous dire quelque chose c'est la
personne la plus sympathique du monde
d'ailleurs et ça va être pas
très intelligent
Alzheimer c'est fini pas du tout mais
j'ai pas dit quand je dirais tout à
l'heure non non le jour où on fermera
Twitter je vous jure que la qualité des
émissions de télévision vont enfin
monter j'ai vu des scènes parfois même
quand même 6 pour pas les citer enlever
une séquence ou paniquer sur un Pékin
Express parce qu'il y avait eu 2000
tweets sur une émission qui fait 3
millions de connards et ils étaient en
panique mais je vais vous donner un
exemple où on remonte vous le savez les
émissions de la vérité qui compte on est
en 2002 2004 à l'époque je me lâche un
peu de temps en temps on coupe
aujourd'hui quand je dis à une fille qui
a 20 ans ma grande
ou ma belle mes équipes me disent ma
belle ça fait condescendance ça fait le
mec machin donc on coupe je te dis même
20 ans plus tard tu fais attention à ce
que à ce que aurek sont des gens voilà
donc c'est un peu bizarre c'est un vrai
problème
[Rires]
il y a cette espèce de pensée comme ça
en tube la pensée cylindrique la pensée
unique qui vient mais tacler alors que
en fait il y a des gens qui sont nés en
Afrique qui ont du sang africain par
exemple le fils de Yannick Noah il est
blanc il est blond et il se sent noir à
l'intérieur aussi enfin il y a un prof
enfin je vois pas la vraie vie dans la
vraie vie de tous les gens les gens qui
viennent vous voir sur les gentils et
ceux qui écrivent sur les méchants donc
Twitter c'est de la merde on continue
mon shoot sinon on allait à demain
sur l'épaule d'une des personnes qui
étaient sur le plateau ça a été tourné
on a demandé ce qu'on refasse la
séquence dans un tu as mis la main sur
l'épaule ça ne se fait pas mais c'est
chiant ici